this is not a remnant of a melted
glacier it's an artificial water
reservoir the shape of which is
reminiscent of a Buddhist sanctuary a
stupa made of ice the idea was conceived
by Sonam Wangchuck an engineer from
Ladakh in northwestern India shapes
which have minimal surface area for the
volume so the Sun cannot melt it as
quickly as it does horizontal flat ice
and therefore it melts slowly as the
summer approaches and as it melts it
gives its water to the farmers Ladakh is
famous for the world's highest altitude
cold desert in a region which gets only
between 50 to 100 millimetres of
rainfall annually the glaciers have been
a life source for ages they provide
water for the cities and for the farmers
as well but due to climate change
almost 20% of the glaciers in the area
have been lost in the last 50 years
although the glaciers melt during summer
time there is still water scarcity
during certain months what many people
don't understand for farmers the
challenge of water is only in springtime
April May which is when they need water
and which is when the glaciers are still
not warm enough up there that means they
don't melt a wooden scaffold serves as a
skeleton for the ice stupa in winter
scarce meltwater from the mountains is
transported in underground pipes to
lower regions
due to the difference in pressure it
shoots up all by itself and the minus 20
air will extract the heat in the water
and then it falls down and freezes in
the shape of a cone and the beauty is
that you don't need machines or pumps or
electricity or fuels or pollution none
of that it's all gravity simple pipes
it's summer now this stupa is five
months old
built by the inhabitants of a nearby
village originally it held over 15
million liters of water about 50,000
litres melt daily with the water flowing
from the eye stupa the village in the
valley has enough water available for
the timely irrigation of the fields
sanam wangchuk is co-founder of the
students educational and cultural
movement sec mall because the young
people will one day have a say in the
fate of the region they need to know how
the stupas help the farmers however in
the long run
artificial glaciers are only a makeshift
solution not just a method of making
water but it is also a message from the
mountain people to the people in big
cities of the world it is equally
important that you in the big cities do
everything to mitigate climate change
and change your lifestyle so my message
is that please live simply in the big
cities of the world so that we in the
mountains can simply live there are now
about 25 I stupas in the region to
create them it needed just a leap of the
imagination what's needed now is change
on a global scale